[Música]
olá maravilhosos hoje pensa em uma
palavra ou uma frase para a seguinte
questão porque elas simplesmente não vai
embora em contexto de violência
doméstica porque provavelmente nas
representações sociais aqui no
imaginário apareceram porque ela gosta
de apanhar a mulher de malandro e cega
depende dele financeiramente não tem
coragem
nessa trajetória conheci um homem que me
relatou que aos cinco anos de idade
assistiu o próprio pai assassinar a mãe
maria por ciúmes
vamos agora juntos redes construir essas
representações sobre as mulheres que
vivem relacionamentos abusivos e estava
bom
vamos juntos diagnósticos que não
sangram precisão nos impactar sob pena
do desaquecimento daquilo que é mais
importante nós que é o caráter humano e
falar de relacionamento abusivo é falar
de dificuldades portanto esses
diagnósticos que não sangram como por
exemplo o brasil está no quinto lugar no
ranking mundial
em femininos sítios portanto são 5.000
mortas ao ano 13 mil mortas ao dia
isso tudo segundo dados da onu mulheres
de 2015 ea maior parte mulheres negras
portanto é um recorte racial e étnico
para complicar a pesquisa do ipea traz
pra nós que diante da afirmação uma
pesquisa realizada em 212 municípios em
2013 muito recente
diante da afirmação mulheres que usam
poucas roupas gosta ou pedem pra apanhar
estamos no século 21
mas 26% das pessoas concordam totalmente
ou parcialmente com isso e mais diante
da afirmativa mulher que é agredida e
continua com o parceiro gosta de apanhar
61% das pessoas concordam totalmente ou
parcialmente com essa afirmativa a tese
de doutorado demonstra de violências no
relacionamento afetivo onde há
expectativas de um porto seguro de
cumplicidade e com quem se investiram
sonhos projetos filhos sexualidade
sentimento de natureza positiva sim amor
desejo eo prazer sentimento de ser
cuidada e protegida e sentimentos
negativos como raiva ódio é muito
diferente de violência com alguém
próximo
ou seja é muito diferente de violência
com quem é próximo de viver violência
com quem é extraído conhecido é preciso
a gente levar isso em conta tem
especificidades e nesse sentido nesses
casos a pessoa que vive o problema
demora a acreditar que quem ela pensa
que ama e que é amada não ama e por
estar envolvida nessa situação demora a
perceber que o parceiro por vezes comete
violência desses casos censuras e desse
modo na ousadia do contar-se e de sair
da invisibilidade
eu destaco trechos da história de uma
mulher
trechos de uma história duramente
adquirida onde as cenas as queixas e os
desfechos nos fazem entender melhor o
que se passa e porque é que elas
permanecem e entre os fatores que
dificultam a busca de ajuda e dá um
basta
eu vou citar vários deles e para cada
caso a configuração é única
a visão idealizada ouve se muito
tudo era lindo no começo era o meu
príncipe encantado ea cuidar de mim
a crença de que a violência é temporária
resultado de uma fase difícil que eu
posso mudar o outro
imagina a gente passa uma vida e não
consegue se modifica o receio de
possíveis dificuldades econômicas na
falta dele mas muitas delas sustentam os
lares e portanto a dependência nem
sempre é financeira mas emocional a
situação dos filhos como é que vai ficar
se tiver ficha na polícia se ele for
preso ele ficar desempregado então olha
como é complexa situação os sentimentos
de culpa e por vezes ele distorce a
situação e aí ela o tempo todo mas o que
eu fiz afinal de contas então o
sentimento de culpa é importante ou pena
dele e aí o argumento de que a ele possa
as coisas dentro de casa é um bom pai só
fica agressivo quando bebe o pa
mas quando ele bebe ele não bate no
companheiro no boteco e nem um chefe da
empresa não ser aquele bate porque bebe
além de tudo isso essa sensação também
de que no fundo ele está sofrendo não
tenho pena dele está sofrendo ainda mais
a vergonha dos filhos de ser vista como
espancada
muitas vezes depois que o bicho pega é
que as pessoas perguntam mas nossa
parecia que era um casal tão bacana né
a falta de apoio familiar quando o
problema é compartilhado e ouvi
comentários do tipo a homem assim mesmo
está ruim com ele pior sem ele
uma hora passa aguentem um pouquinho que
passa o medo pois ele ameaça se ela sair
fora enfim de terno de relacionamento ea
gente acompanha os casos pelo mundo
afora no brasil
ele vai me matar e ele diz vou começar a
aparecer no próximo seu trabalho vou te
tirar o menino não vou te deixar em paz
e é claro a autoestima vai sendo
bombardeada alto vale o amor próprio vai
pro lixo
inclusive ela se sente um lixo os
depoimentos vai nessa linha
me sinto um lixo nada ele diz que eu sou
a pior me mulher a pior mulher de todas
que ele já teve
a louca a burra a fé ea chorona a gorda
e aí uma série de outros adjetivos bem
depreciativos e ela vai acreditando ter
um amor que merece ter e que não vai ter
outra chance
uma outra possibilidade outra pessoa
isso um histórico de abuso de desamparo
que por vezes começa lá na família de
origem pessoas têm história
a falta de informações também contribui
para isso diz casey de recursos eu de ou
então os desafios é nas estruturas
judiciárias de delegacias especializadas
de atendimento
muitas vezes inclusive essas delegacias
não funciona em sistema de plantão
lembrando que a maior parte dos casos de
violência doméstica acontecem à noite
aos finais de semana que é quando o
casal passa encontra e elas estão
fechadas
também pesa o receio de ficar sozinha o
isolamento social imposto por ele não
vai encontrar com a família não vai
encontrar com os amigos não pode isso
não pode aquilo que penso que vai com
essa luta
além disso o receio de ficar sozinha e o
isolamento social tem uma questão
importante grave que a interpretação
religiosa de conformação que pode
auxiliar na perpetuação desse problema
então fala do tipo eu fui criada pra
ficar uma vida inteira se o que deus
uniu o homem não separa se roer o osso
tem que comer carne
quem sabe em outra vida vai ter
melhorias ou então que é uma maldição de
que passou de pai para filho de mãe para
filha
mas há também é interessante isso
aquelas pessoas aquelas mulheres e essa
que eu tô contando também que se apóiam
na fé como força pra escapar dessas
situações a gente tem que ter uma fé
inteligente e não acreditar em tudo que
querem impor na gente
é compreensível que algumas vezes ela
opte por desfazer a denúncia e retorna
e para essa rotina dolorosa que ainda
lhe garante alguma mínima estrutura de
vida na história dessa mulher ela
menciona o pesadelo das fugas na
madrugada já dormi investida junto com
as crianças esperam ter o sono pesado
para sair fugido da situação na história
dessa mulher também
a gente sabe que existem casas abrigo em
alguns locais mas nem sempre elas são
visibilizadas divulgadas casas abrigos
são locais confidenciais para as
mulheres serem promovidas nem tão
endereço e sigiloso aquelas que estão em
violência doméstica em situação de risco
junto com seus filhos menores de idade
podem ir a esses locais
mas nem sempre funcionam ou existem em
uma dessas tentativas várias de apoio
essa mulher comenta
eu estava confuso sentir pressão
precisava de acolhimento ea forma dos
profissionais chegar em mim tá errada eu
passei anos vem da autoridade tirando
onda da minha situação da minha cara
tratando tudo como banalidade
fui inclusive cantada por um advogado
diz uma delas
até de maria batalhão foi chamada pela
polícia militar pela quantidade de
ocorrências policiais que eu fiz e mais
um juiz disse que o que estava lhe
faltando era religião e me aconselhou a
ir para o motel como agressor
meu marido agressor ao invés de realizar
o trabalho deles o dever de casa é
perceptível que nesses jogos de poder
há também as violências institucionais
então já passa por toda uma série de
violências e ainda tem as violências
institucionais e que certas organizações
sofrem do mal que desejam combater sejam
os procedimentos nas práticas com
humilhações julgamento moral exposição
na coleta de provas é na demora das
medidas protetivas são previstas na lei
pra 48 e 72 horas leva um mês já morreu
além da rara formação continuada de
profissionais que atendem e devem
praticar aquilo que a gente chama de
escuta
tive que escuta ativa é uma escuta que
compreende a particularidade de cada
caso as pessoas não são feitas no
atacado ou seja uma escuta sem
preconceitos sem culpabiliza ções é ao
buscar apoio ela ouve de tudo por
exemplo por que não buscar ajuda antes a
mas o que estava fazendo para provocar
ou têm certeza mesmo que você tem que
denunciar o seu marido
esse percurso é óbvio que ele pode levar
a toda uma descrença dos serviços
prestados e como a gente pode constatar
também são vários mecanismos para
submeter o outro e que orientam tanto
condutas de quem vive a situação de
violência doméstica quanto à conduta de
profissionais que realizam atendimentos
o escritor rubem alves muito
interessante ele trata do relacionamento
tipo tênis e frescobol
não vamos comigo aqui nessa história
quantos elementos que nós utilizamos
para jogar frescobol que tem o frescor
bom gente uma bola que mais duas
raquetes
existe também uma rede que separam dois
advertiu
qual é o objetivo do jogo de tênis
eu jogo a bola de um jeito bastante
difícil de modo que o outro deixe a bola
cair
então quando um ganha o outro pet
esse é o objetivo do jogo de tênis e tem
relacionamento tipo tênis mas nós temos
um outro tipo de jogo frescobol muito
jogado em praias gramas enfim frescobol
também tem uma bola tem o que mais duas
raquetes mas não tem rede porque é que
não existem a dever salários qual é o
objetivo do frescobol jade eu joga a
bola isso mesmo o melhor possível para
que o outro
pegue
dk joga o melhor possível para que de lá
pegue porque só tem jogo no ganha ganha
com o objetivo do frescobol não deixar a
bola cair então lamentavelmente nós
temos muito mais gente jogando tênis que
frescobol tem aspectos que também
contribuem para relacionamentos
violentos por exemplo os contextos
sócio-culturais e simbólicos o padrão
sexista machista não gostava de machismo
que parece que as riquezas circularidade
cultural pela cabeça de machos mas
também não quero culpabilizar as
mulheres por mais nada já basta a
tradição judaico-cristã do pecado
original mas queria pensar junto o
quanto que isso está incorporado está
dentro de nós e inclusive as definições
que vamos fazendo de funções sociais
desiguais para homens e mulheres com
reforço do do ciúme viria o possessivo
de verificar o outro como extensão com
propriedade e isso ocorre muito a partir
inclusive da educação diferenciada para
meninos e meninas ao invés da educação
que a gente chama integral à educação
onde o lugar dos gêneros pode ser em
todos os lugares em casa por exemplo a
divisão das tarefas
nós construímos nossa casa eu acompanhei
a obra servente pedreiro etc
é o ricardo que inclusive está na
platéia ricardo que eu tô pegando 19
anos levanta a mão ligado aqui
aliás quem como somos nós anatomicamente
dizendo mas isso é uma outra conversa é
porque o cometa associada relações de
poder e linguagem também não é neutro do
ponto de vista de gênero mas em casa
então companhia a obra
ricardo faz supermercado toda semana
portanto dividimos tarefas e cuidados
por habilidades e competências e os
nossos filhos um de 15 anos e hoje está
com 12 também com certeza brincaram de
boneca de casinha para já a treinarem-se
um dia fizer a escolha de serem pais e
de ter uma casa para cuidar e brincaram
de bola para desenvolver a coordenação
motora
porque os brinquedos brincadeiras não
são neutros do ponto de vista de gênero
cria um cenário inclusive para essa
violência ou para a cultura da
não-violência e nesse sentido é bom
lembrar também que tarefas domésticas
são realizadas com as mãos e não com as
genitálias portanto tarefa de todos os
membros da família e acho bom reforçar
tudo isso aqui
além disso as discussões sobre as
construções de gênero na educação formal
e informal para se lidar com conflitos
sem precisar lançar mão do recurso da
violência e conflito em toda relação mas
não é preciso ter violência é pelo
contrário
primando pelo respeito pela tolerância
pelo diálogo e por aquilo que a gente
chama de construção da cultura da paz
a violência ela deixa marcas no corpo e
na alma não é só física mas também
psicológica emocional moral patrimonial
patrimonial no caso de destruição de
objetos de documentos inviabilizando a
pessoa de ir e vir quebradeiras em casa
por exemplo e pode ser entendida como um
recurso extremo para manter as mulheres
no seu devido lugar de suposta
inferioridade e muitas interpretações e
tornar esse micro em macro poder
essa violência é bastante democrática
tinha todas as raças e etnias faixas
etárias classes sociais
os comportamentos agressivos dos autores
de violência
eles também denunciam a sua fragilizada
autoestima receio da perda insegurança
porque se não precisariam lançar mão do
recurso da violência a gente verifica
isso nas narrativas daqueles que são
atendidos
é importante que todos nós possamos
contribuir para a divulgação da
legislação de políticas públicas
políticas públicas de estado e o estado
deve ser laico ou seja sem
direcionamento religioso e atendendo à
pluralidade de possibilidades e para o
exercício das da cidadania plena a gente
poder auxiliar inclusive a reduzir uma
série de fatores um deles a
revitimização ou seja a pessoa contar a
sua história em
vários locais várias vezes e aí vira uma
via crucis isso também inibe a busca de
ajuda
o ciclo dessas violências que por vezes
é composto pela tensão
aí vem a agressão depois a lua-de-mel
pede desculpa perdão nunca mais vai
acontecer e aí a crença de que o outro
vai mudar e eu posso mudar o outro enfim
é claro que também a gente pensar na
possibilidade do espiral porque o ciclo
parece fechado o espiral ele abre
possibilidades de escapatórias modo
fator a lentidão dos procedimentos
o desencorajamento na impunidade quando
ela acontece
a ausência de registros precisos em
diagnóstico fica complicado inclusive
política pública
um outro aspecto importante aquele homem
que me disse ter assistido ao
assassinato da própria mãe maria lá no
início da nossa conversa
ele é meu pai depois dessa marca
ele não conseguiu ser pai e nem esposo o
que revela os impactos dessa violência
em todos os membros da família ea mãe se
separou dele eu tinha sete anos e foi um
alívio e foi dependente químico a vida
inteira teve um câncer fruto da bebida
faleceu em 2011 e eu tiver oportunidade
três meses antes do seu falecimento
junto com meu esposo com os familiares
de ser filha dele poder ser avô dos meus
filhos e de poder cuidar dele na nossa
casa
eu sou muito grata por ter tido essa
chance
minha mãe outra maria que escapou
contando com o apoio da família estudou
foi trabalhar fora depois de separar e
dois de nós os quatro filhos e avó
paterna a maria assassinada ela se foi
no entanto deixou legado eu
como parte de um coletivo com potencial
multiplicador que assumir essa missão
voluntária de décadas de poder auxiliar
outras marias e às suas famílias
eu gosto e utilizo e deve está
percebendo na borboleta
a alegoria que também no do sul o boleto
na flor de lótus porque é bastante
significativa borboleta ela sai né do
lagarto rastejante que come folhas
defeca passa pelo casulo momento de auto
reflexão quem está de fora parece que
aquilo ali nada acontecendo casos da
crisálida parece que está paralisado
nada acontecendo mas por dentro profunda
transformação
e aqui no caso na flor de lótus que é
uma flor que se nutre do lodo e do caso
da crisálida sair uma livre leve com
vários olhos borboleta
gostaria que nós nos inspiramos e raul
vão comigo ser essa metamorfose
ambulante do que ter aquela velha
opinião formada sobre tudo de novo
eu prefiro ser essa metamorfose
ambulante vamos lá do que ter aquela
velha opinião formada sobre tudo
e esses exemplos de superação e dessas
várias marias encontramos em lei em
mulheres que são apoiadas pela
sonoridade empatia uma sobe e puxa a
outra
percebem agora que é possível mas não é
tão simples assim embora percebe
portanto tentemos não julgar para que
haja mais marias com força
gana e força sempre se a violência
existe ela pode se intensificar e a cada
dois minutos uma mulher é agredida e
nesses 18 minutos digital que como vocês
podem ver pelo cronômetro
aproximadamente 40 mulheres foram
espancadas e correram risco de serem
assassinadas
e é nessa conexão onde a violência
conjugal e contra a mulher que todos
perdem e a família saiu machucada e por
isso é preciso convido vocês a comigo
metemos a colher grata pela oportunidade
[Aplausos]